el expresidente Jair bolso deberá
testificar ante la Policía Federal en el
caso de los disturbios del 8 de enero es
lo que ordenó un juez del supremo
tribunal Federal Solo dos semanas
después del regreso del ex mandatario a
Brasil
Mesías bolsonaro deberá ser escuchado
por la policía federal en un plazo
máximo de 10 días hasta ahora bolso no
ha comentado la orden este famoso día de
enero miles de sus seguidores asaltaron
las sedes de los poderes en Brasilia
pidiendo una intervención militar para
remover a luisina cholulada Silva del
poder que llevaba una semana en el cargo
bolsonaro que se encontraba en Estados
Unidos en este momento no condenó los
eventos la Corte Suprema buscará saber
si el expresidente incitó este
movimiento o incluso participó en su
planificación algo que él niega después
de su derrota frente a Lula Jair
bolsonaro savia auxiliado a Estados
Unidos durante tres meses y regresó a
Brasil el 30 de marzo desde su llegada
ha sido objeto de varias investigaciones
en total se enfrenta a cuatro procesos
en el supremo tribunal federal y a una
decena de casos ante el tribunal
electoral superior de Brasil en uno de
estos se da juzgado en las próximas
semanas respecto a sus campañas de
discreto contra el sistema de votación
electrónico al ser reconocido culpable
podría perder sus derechos políticos
durante ocho años